do you know everybody in town the deed
show bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu
alaikum the wonderful greeting a piece
that were greeting you with thank you
for tuning in to another episode of the
Deen show today we're going to be
discussing some of the common questions
that some non-muslims might ask or even
that the Muslims get confused about good
and evil there's a God where does it
come from this idea of God being 3 and 1
the Trinity and other common
misconceptions and questions that people
have
so don't go nowhere we'll be right back
you can sing along with this wonderful
song and we'll be here with our next
guest on the Dane show Allah Allah
there's only one word is His Messenger
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
assalamualaikum doctor luck you're my
brother
how you doing it happy I get you back
here with us on the Dean so happy to be
back on the Dean show you got to keep
coming back brother
my pleasure keep inviting me I'll keep
coming back that's right okay we get
down to business because you know what
we have so much to talk about and always
so little time but we want to give the
people a taste of this beautiful way of
life we're like all the messengers Islam
the submission to the One God right in
peace talk to us now there's some
questions common questions that when
Muslims are talking to non-muslims and
even Muslims amongst themselves that are
trying to get supposed Muslims who are
non practicing practicing and then some
of these arguments that we might see for
us ridiculous but there's easy ways to
answer them so we want to give the tools
the people the ability when someone
comes and just throw something at you
now you're stumped so talk about some of
these things that you've encountered
share with us and give some common
replies to them great
first of all bismillah khan rahim and
hamdulillah or salat wa salam ala allah
in the name of allah the most merciful
the compassionate and may he extolled
and send blessings of peace upon his
final messenger muhammad so basically
you know a lot of times people think
that their job is just to answer
questions a lot of muslims feel that you
know I'm here to tell you about Islam
feel free to ask me questions and so
whatever question is thrown at them they
respond and hopefully we're hoping that
in this episode people will learn other
ways of answering questions and from the
responses perhaps both Muslims and
non-muslims can benefit from the answer
to the question because when you think
your job is just to answer questions you
begin to answer no matter how ridiculous
the question is for example sometimes
and I'm gonna repeat some of the the
example have been giving over the years
same examples yeah sometimes someone
will come to you and say can God create
a four-sided triangle and you know a
Muslim will be like yes of course you
can create anything but then what kind
of a question is that there's no such
thing as a four-sided triangle yes the
minute there's a fourth side it's a
rectangle or it's a square but there's
no such thing so that guy you see it's a
question exactly he needs to go back to
you know whatever mathematics where what
level where they teach you that yeah
triangle has three sides but don't just
start answering those questions or will
someone will ask you something like why
does Allah need us to worship Him and so
immediately you start to give a fancy
answer because he's deserving of worship
no matter how fancy you make it you're
wrong yeah because you didn't fix the
question because the guy said what is
Allah need us to worship Him you need to
fix the question he doesn't need us to
worship Him no matter how eloquently you
respond to that question he walks away
thinking Allah doesn't need us to
worship Him yes we gotta fix the
question I'll tell you and and sometimes
in fixing the question you give a
valuable lesson one time I was an again
I'm repeating in the popular stories
that I've told before I was working at
this company and this man and non-muslim
asked me he said why do Muslims always
grow their beards Yeah right
and I know what he's asking me that
question because he shaves yeah and
people around him shave but he shouldn't
be asking me that's why I grow my beard
I should be asking him why he shaves
yeah I wanted to understand that so I
said well I understand why you're asking
me that question but to be honest I
don't grow it it comes out by itself
naturally yeah and I mean I don't put
manure yeah and then I didn't put water
and sunlight and then it comes over
itself actually like the grass from the
soil exactly yeah I told him it and
that's what happens and even children
understand this concept because you
could tell the child draw the face of a
man and a woman he'll immediately add
facial hair to the man because when a
male reaches puberty he sprouts facial
hair yeah so I don't do anything to grow
my hair you're the one it's growing for
you naturally as well but you insist on
removing every stubble every morning
yeah so when I gave him that answer he
actually thought about it and he started
to tell me I'll try to quote him he said
you know
I never thought of it of it that way but
you should be asking me why I shave
mm-hmm because now when you know we got
him to rethink his question one time
someone was giving a lecture on the slam
to a Muslim audience the the men were to
the left the woman were to the right and
the woman of course they were dressed in
their veil and their job so a non-muslim
woman came in yelling she was angry she
was pointing at the woman why are they
covered like that yeah so then he looked
at her and he said well you're covered
as well worried and you were born naked
why are you covered
she said modesty yeah it's a wall just
like your mother's by being covered
there are being a bit more modest by
being covered a bit more so immediately
it made her think that she shouldn't be
asking this question to begin with
because you know it's what's wrong with
being covered you're covered yeah I mean
you're not undressed because you know
there's this assumption that if you wear
hijab that you're oppressed right and
the more you take remove of clothing the
more free you are but then realistically
that means then if you have some kind of
clothing some level of clothing on you
you're not 100 percent free so and and I
would say don't do this all right don't
make the argument but you could always
argue well you need to liberate yourself
a little bit more yourself you're not
100% free yeah take it all off but don't
I don't absolutely not
so basically it's getting people to look
at their question again don't you start
answering it someone told you about it
three four-sided triangles don't answer
that question
yeah he needs to understand that that's
not that's not a right question so
initially we're talking about Allah no
you we're going to take a break okay as
Sigmund and we'll be right back on
all of the property will be enabled
because the essential message with the
same submission this is God talking to
you how can I stand behind the pulpit on
Sunday morning and preach a sermon that
I knew was variance with the actual
taproot of christianity back here with
my brother and your brother came al l
mecki mecki absolutely talk to a shape
continue on all right you know sometimes
even muslims will ask some really weird
questions you know and if they think
about it they start to understand it
like sometimes a woman would say a
muslim woman will say something like how
come there wasn't any female prophet
sent to humanity yeah are you serious
think about it alright and one of the
jobs of the Prophet they got a lead
armies battle sometimes the problem
would walk for two months to get to a
location right for two straight months
and now this is a female prophet she's
got to lead all these men into battle
I don't know how tough she's gonna be in
battle besides that then she it's that
time of the month and his crimes and her
legs hurt and she has to walk like that
yeah and then she's pregnant for nine
months and she still has to lead the
prayers and I mean come on think about
your question first then she has a mood
swing and then and then what who knows
what rulings he'll come up with right
yeah and then also sometimes we'll say
things like why can't a woman marry for
men are you objecting and this is a
blessing for you can't marry for men but
enough putting up with one guy no that's
not the reason the real reason is that
imagine the woman has to take care of
four men cook for four men take care of
four men's homes and bear children for
four men it's impossible so but think
about your question before you ask it so
anyways when someone asks you a question
in in response try to keep the response
simple and keep it direct and to the
don't don't just come out and be anxious
now to answer think rationally about
what the question that came at you was
that's number one think about that
question don't just start answering yeah
fix it if there's something wrong with
the question itself to try to give a
simple answer and a simple explain
first a lot of people love to come with
the philosophical and big argument in
big words and keep it simple
all right simple you get everybody yeah
right so that's the other thing keep it
simple and three be direct be right to
the point
a lot of times you ask someone a
question and they'll go around telling
you a long story no answer my question
yeah because it looks like you're being
evasive Lee don't answer the call us
some more common questions that have
people stumped and they're actually easy
to answer all right sometimes you need
to think you need to go a little bit you
know back to before that could look for
example popular analogies people make
people will tell you like for example
will tell you the Trinity they'll
compare it to an egg they'll tell you
the Trinity is like an egg it has the
shell it has the yolk and it has the
white three things one egg this is when
someone now you're talking about
monotheism God is one one one and then
they talk about three and they try to
make sense of it and the totally Trinity
is one yeah until how could three be one
they give you an example of an egg it
has the show the white the yolk three
things one egg the Father the Son the
Spirit three things one God you know but
the problem is that you know the in the
in the Trinity the triune God is
physically separate yeah so if you have
the the Sun physically on earth the
father physically in the heavens the
spirit wherever the spirit may be these
are physical three physical locations
that are separate if we separate the
ingredients of the egg it's not called
an egg anymore you know if I put the
whiting over here the yolk over there
the shell over there when you see the
shell you're gonna say hey look it's an
egg shell you're not gonna say look
that's an egg you know so because you
physically separated them they don't
become one thing anymore yeah and
there's nothing on earth that's
physically separate and still wone yeah
you can argue one in essence like one
time this ask this one person he
basically said yeah lutherie and there's
still one so I said okay if there are
three bottles of water on the table how
many bottles of water are on the table
there's three physically separate you
can argue that they're one in essence
that they're all it's all plastic and
it's all water but the reality is there
are three physically separate bottles of
water you can't say oh it's all one you
know so it can
be if they're physically separate that
they're still one so the analogy doesn't
work many the way you would explain that
question or that analogy is that you
just basically take it apart because
it's an energy it's it's it's a wrong
analogy you know the triune God
according to them it's separate and this
is something that's together once you
separate this egg it's not an egg
anymore it's not one thing okay I've got
a trickier one for you yeah they'll tell
you okay it's actually like water yeah
water is one thing but it can be a solid
or a liquid or a gas
so God the Father the solid the liquid
is the Sun and the gas the spirit yeah
it's water but it's three you know and
actually it's I've heard you know
experience that going to lengths to try
to refute the water analogy but the
analogy is really really simple
yeah people believe the Trinity is three
and one not one and three because if
they say one and three they're admitting
to worshipping three gods the Trinity is
according to them three and one yeah so
you can't give me an example of one and
three to explain three-in-one this the
example of the water is one thing water
in three different states so you can't
use an example of one in three to
explain three in one so yeah that's it
end of story yeah we don't need to go
back and forth that's it it's a wrong
analogy it doesn't work and we've
actually used this with people with
missionaries with people who were very
well versed in the Bible gave us this
examples I'm sorry you said it's three
and one and now you're giving me an
example of one and three yeah end of
story and our concept is that this is
obviously to refute the argument but
people don't even get into this argument
it's just one leave it alone at that
exactly and and you know what one is the
easiest thing to comprehend yeah and
it's the is the easiest thing for you to
understand and it makes so much sense to
you if you try to go to a child now
that's six seven eight years old and you
try to tell them look God is one
you could probably explain this in under
a minute absolutely what if you try to
do this whole silicon or any other
number like polytheism then that's one
of the things that is difficult to
comprehend about polytheism if somebody
tells you there are seven gods yeah
okay which one is the toughest one if
you like them that number one all right
now worship number one who cares about
the other five of the six they're weak
yeah I wish the tough one he'll take
care of me on the day of judgment all
right or what if someone tells you well
they're all equal but one of them is the
God of love the other is a God of anger
the others to go to war well the God of
anger it's gonna take me a lot of time
to make him happy I worship the God of
love yeah so then they could never be
equal you know because I'm just going to
pick this one you know so if someone
says no they're absolutely equal in
their characteristics in their
descriptions then what if 75% of the
people worship God number three and the
others worship that means he now is not
equal to the rest because he's
worshipped more than the others so
there's the concept of like having more
than one God it actually doesn't make
sense and it's not easy to digest the
concept of Trinity is very easy for
people to understand I'm sorry the
concept of tohave which is one God very
easy to understand you tell people three
gods that are physically separate but
there's still one and then one of them
dies for three days and there's still
three I'm just go one just confusion
very Trinity is just confusing it's
man-made it's not something from the
divine I'll tell you something Eddie
okay and and I'm not going on on a limb
by saying this there is nobody on the
face of the planet that totally
understands Trinity meaning he he
digested and fathoms the concept there
are people who believe in it very much
so but there's nobody who totally
understand it because it's a concept
that doesn't make sense yeah they can't
be something that's three and separate
but still one who was the one who
started to really he was going into this
and the more he went into it he Ares
well it was Saint Athanasius Anthony
that that thing is that you know he is
known as if you're looking up he's known
as the father of the Trinity father okay
here's the more I think about it the
more confused I become so now if he's
the one who said that now you're gonna
come across like you figured it out
you're lying to yourself and every
analogy you come up with it's not going
to work there's nothing on this planet
that's physical and physically separate
and still one yeah it just doesn't work
like so when men a few men come into a
room and they try to conspire and try to
make
something a religion they might get them
in some crazy way to fit with them maybe
possibly maybe not but try to sell it to
the world no way but the religion from
the crater the way of life that the
crater sends down it fits it has to fit
with everyone absolutely should one got
lost meant to him and that was the easy
message Jesus himself that's it there's
one God that's one guy that's it tell us
now some people they'll argue the
question good and evil all loving God
what's up with the evil talk to us right
and actually just yesterday someone kept
saying why did Allah plan for things to
be like this you know why is it that a
believer will suffer why is it that
there's agony when you die why is it
this why is it that why did he why did
he do all of this put us on earth why do
we go through all so so this person
basically now and he's asking a lot of
why why why and one of it one of the
ways that you can you can fix that you
can either give analogies or you can
give them the floor so I said okay how
would you do it and no way they're gonna
come up with a better plan than Allah is
plan the Minnesota ask them say okay
smart man smart woman how would you do
it exactly what would you think there's
why should we suffer why should be there
be suffering on earth okay what do you
want to happen that yeah like a lot of
times non-muslims would ask me
well if why does God allow bad things to
happen if there's a good guy he's fixing
his roof and he falls
why should he Burt his bones break well
then I asked him what do you want to
happen big mattress will suddenly appear
underneath him or a hand will catch him
and then nobody trips nobody Falls
nobody gets cut nobody gets any kind of
pain and so then nobody knows the like
when you don't know the pain you don't
know the sweetness of being in good
health and you know you know the
opposites so you can appreciate it more
when you know the bad you know
appreciate the good more so what do you
want to happen here then they realize
that well then that means I wanted life
that's a utopia and I want God to
intervene in everything nobody loses
their car keys nobody Falls nobody dies
nobody gets hurt and that's not what the
point is we have free will it's not
supposed to be like that so when you
give them the floor okay how do you
think things should be immediately from
the first Center start to make mistakes
because obviously they couldn't
possibly give you a better plan than the
plan of Allah obviously you know or
sometimes you just tell someone okay
look this is the reality what are you
gonna do about it I mean one time this
person was telling me why did that luck
later so he explained all right so but
why then you explain again why then you
run out of knowledge I mean we don't
have infinite knowledge I mean I can't
tell you why
behind every plan Allah had so I ran out
of knowledge do you have some some live
examples or something where someone
would say well why did this again it
goes back to why this innocent child had
to suffer or Wars tsunamis mudslides
right like well first of all let me give
you some analogies where people will say
why is there evil on earth if God is so
good so I'll tell them okay give me and
I will stand out in the Sun in broad
daylight
I'll give you a glass jar give it back
to me full of darkness can you do that
no they say no well why not
because darkness then doesn't exist in
and of itself it only exists as a result
of the lack of something else which is
light yeah so we tell them look evil
Allah didn't command evil on earth he
commanded good but when we choose to
disregard the light of a lot of the
guidance of Allah what happens you get
darkness not only it works so well there
I mean the last time I tried it someone
was asking me why is there evil I said
given the analogy with the darkness
immediately like okay
I understand what you're saying yeah so
they start to see that when we don't
follow the light of Allah the darkness
the evil comes yeah you know or you can
use cold and did you hear the the
analogy of the barber and the man who
was cutting his hair he came to the
barber did you hear that one I I think I
did hear but maybe you can I heard it a
couple times whenever you could fill it
in where he was they were having a
debate back and forth and then the the
the question arose about the existence
of God then the I'm trying to sum it up
make it quick
the barber who's cutting his hair he
said God don't exist and he brought up
the argument about good and evil how
could there be a God if all this evil so
the person who's got his hair cut he
didn't want argue he left then he came
back and he said well look I don't
believe in barbers he said how you see
I'm here I said we'll look at all those
people out there look at him are all
shaggy and you know dirty yeah he said
well yeah that's because they've chosen
not to come to me so now he related this
exactly you know this is what happens
when you go away from beautiful crater
did very much yes I read and I totally
forgot it huh because so but what he did
here basically he got the man to to
recognize the existence of Allah or he
got him to think about it in a different
way by using some kind of analogy or
some kind of you know reality from from
the world at there and which is a
technique also we got to cut to a break
right back on the D show also say to me
why have you become a Muslim no I give a
very frivolous on so I say I want to be
on the side of the angels [ __ ] is a guy
he's the number-one rap artists in the
world he sold over 60 million records
worldwide a million Steve Miller he was
a young guy where basically everything
that somebody who would think that life
was all about he had everything you can
imagine
I will continuing on talking about some
of the questions we covered the
analogies that people try to justify to
Trinity which easily refuted God is one
worship worship him alone and we talked
about the good and evil and also there's
another common argument that people try
to make and they say you know what
religions are the cause of all the wars
right I don't want to follow any
organized religion I'm just going to
basically make my own religion I mean
my own thing this is the case when when
you would refute such an argument using
you know using the reality using history
using science using statistics using
facts the truth is this is not a true
statement yet many people will say it
and the constantly repeated that don't
talking about religion more people die
because of religion than anything else
that's actually not true
and anyone who's a history buff or not
you can just basically go and get a list
of all known Wars or named wars in
recent history or in past history and
make a list and see how many of them
were a hundred percent because of
religion how many of them were because
of land or wealth or money or taking
over in other people's territory and
they brought religion to mix it and to
give it flavor how many were just
strictly because of scripture basically
a Christian or a Muslim open up a book
and said just go kill the other guy
simply because he's not from your faith
and you find it none of them were
actually like that so when you do the
math you find that millions upon
millions of people died fighting over
money fighting over land you know when
we mentioned you know world wars one and
two in World War two it estimated about
55 to 60 million people died I didn't
have anything to do with religion it's
true there was some kind of ideology but
it had nothing to do with religion
that's a large number of people I mean
60 million people or 55 million people
that's not easy I had nothing to do with
religion so when you do the math you'll
find that most people don't die because
of the religion they die because of
money so then that same guy who says I
don't want to talk about religion
because a lot of people die because of
it when he is interviewed for a job he
should say when they asked him how much
do you want to make and the company
I want to talk about money because most
people died because of money more than
anything else you see what I'm saying
yeah but they don't do that but the
thing is it's not true it's factually
incorrect you see but it's become so
popular and many people believe it you
find it all over the place give us a few
examples of a few more things we're
almost out of time some of the other
common
arguments they're easily refuted that
you'd come across okay well sometimes
you you'll use analogies to just kind of
like you did with the barber and so on
there's some popular ones about you know
how did all of this earth come to
existence you know and if you're walking
in the desert and you see a watch on the
ground you're not going to assume that
it just happened to gather in that order
in that fantastically organized way and
just be a coincidence you know and so
it's also ridiculous to assume that you
know order came out of chaos some Big
Bang then all this order and organized
structure came that life came out of no
life consciousness came out of no
consciousness it's it's really too much
and the thing is that most people will
tell you like that I believe in the Big
Bang Theory and this is when you meet an
atheist you ask them okay how do they
come into existence if there is no God
so totally we believe in the Big Bang
Theory and it's it's amazing how quickly
they they're shaken when you tell them
do you know what the theory is I mean
are you basing your life decision on a
theory you know because there are many
evidences to the existence of Allah if
you only look though and if you don't
want to look you you won't see them at
all but you're basing it on a theory
it's not not even proven or anything of
that sort but so many times you know
things are kind of crammed down our
throat as science when a lot of it is
conjecture a lot of it is guesswork and
it's not really anything solidus science
so bottom line is then the answers are
all there no one has to reinvent the
wheel but just just you know you look up
your answers and you package it in a way
that's easy to digest and easier to
comprehend and no need to make
everything too complicated and a big
argument or a big debate tell us now
before we go real quick for those people
who are sincere who want to know the
truth what is at the end of the day what
should they strive towards and we gave
some common rebuttals to the questions
but what's it all about what are we
trying to achieve at the end of the day
at the end of the day anyone who
believes that there is one God and the
same God is the one who sent all the
prophets before with the same basic
message that didn't change the Ten
Commandments never changed worship the
one God never changed this is the same
God that sent the Prophet
muhammad sallallaahu said lem who is a
prophet of islam who comes as a brother
to all the prophets and as a
continuation to their message
so anyone and this is the basic most
basic thing that we want from people if
you believe in Allah that he could have
sent this last messenger muhammad in
Arabia saw a lot of said laughs then you
have the ingredients of what it takes to
become a Muslim that's the first step
then the other things don't worry about
that right now I mean people think if I
become Muslim right now I'll have to
grow beard immediately don't have to
dress like this doctor where I hat you
don't have to do any of that first thing
one God worthy of worship and Mohammed
his servant and his messenger so the
lawyer said that this is a beautiful way
of life is the way of life from the
crater to heaven the earth the way you
give peace we started off with peace we
end with peace and I'll lay colombians
on you to lower the cup and peace is
something that money can't buy and the
more you tune in to the show if you have
any doubts about anything and you want
them cleared up ask the one who created
you it'd only be fair if he gave you the
answers start to use the good old common
sense that he's giving you the tools
that are within your very self and
you'll see that everything that he wants
you to do including worship Him alone
and not his creation it just makes good
old common sense and I know that if you
tuned in with an open heart open mind
the things that we just covered it just
makes good all kind of sense if you want
to argue you can argue about anything
any time but if you want to be sincere
and you want to do what God wants you to
do if you want to submit to him on his
terms this is the right course and the
right direction to take
now come back here every week you can
find us if you don't have the TV if
you're not tuning into the TV all of our
shows all right the Deen show calm we
have our blog section there to interact
with us leave us your comments and your
suggestions also do not forget to pick
up the new DVDs for Dow vol.2 they're
out so you can take this message this
message the peace this message of Islam
this message of worshipping the one God
you can take this and share it with your
colleagues with your fam
with your friends we occurred that you
buy this in bulk so you can share this
message with the world and we'll see you
next time
inshallah God willing I saw making peace
be unto you you have to pray as if
everything depends on allah and it does
but you must work everything depends on
you that's my point you see on the same
and i don't like that i don't like us
sitting here what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
are you waiting for all these people
that come to this club what are you
waiting for
what are we waiting for right now when
they're gonna come they're gonna come
along and bring these people lost upon
the water put in our hand the ability to
do it not do your job